halloween may look different this year
but that doesn't mean you can't have a
little fun
and celebrate with your close friends
and family in a fabulous and spooky way
here to show us how an incredible woman
who worked with martha
stewart for 25 years she is an
author an illustrator an editor
and owner of darcy miller designs but
most importantly
she's my friend please welcome darcy
miller hi bro i i want to give you a hug
i know it it's so weird isn't it our new
normal oh well i'm so excited to be here
and you know it might be different but
it you can it's more
important than ever to make holidays
special now well when i think of
whimsical worlds beauty
i always think of you and darcy and i
actually met
because i stalked darcy to ask her
advice about my wedding with will and
our two beautiful daughters
right and you guided me well you're i've
got so many ideas that frank and oliver
gonna love
so i hope you're gonna go home and do
some of them we're definitely going to
do them and darcy's daughters are
friends
with all of olive and frankie's silly
cousins and we know darcy's daughters so
this is family
and the thing that i love is bringing
darcy's world
to the forefront which it already is i
mean martha stewart for 25 years you
are an empire unto yourself but your
world is so distinct
so give us a few ideas because
tablescapes by the way
are all the rage right now they are so
trending yes and this
is great with if you're celebrating
halloween with your pod or your family
and they're so
easy okay so what you need gourds and
pumpkins
you get them at the grocery store
farmer's market and they're
dressed up with eyeballs because you
can't have spooky halloween without some
eyeballs
you gotta spook a fight exactly so these
are paper eyeballs that i drew
and we have the downloadable clip art
that you can get off the site
darcymiller.com is that the site very
similar designs
darcy miller designs you have to go to
this website we're going to have it up
on the drewberrymore show.com
and we'll bring you glide you right into
darcy's world where you can learn every
single step so easily
um and so again you can do that you can
draw your own
you can add googly eyes it just makes it
really fun i love the little details
like the eek
and i've never seen eyeballs right so
your gourds can see
and speak and we give you the words but
you can write your own
and you this detail also kills me like
the bloody gourd
exactly and you know it could be
whatever you have in the kitchen
zucchinis onion look how cute this onion
is
and i love they're really inexpensive
and a great detail for the table that i
had never seen before
you've never seen an an onion with eyes
um and when i've seen a potato with eyes
and i what i love about this is you can
take the eyes off and then you have
thanksgiving you've got your centerpiece
for thanksgiving that's right you
transfer the gourds and what about these
uh spider webs on the plate
level the rest of these are just all
easy upgrades to things you have at home
taking you know whatever cheesecloth
batting
wrapping on branches or even the um
the plates are taking just a food safe
marker you know that you
write on cookies with and putting a web
on them
and so again you don't need to buy new
plates for halloween you can just
upgrade your own i love this detail too
darcy because i've gone
out and i've been the guy that bought
the cobwebs and then i'm like
where do i put that right we put them
everywhere anywhere ranches
so smart i mean you can put them around
buzzes
and some googly eyes the main thing is
to just have fun with it what is this
this is a blue moon cocktail dude you
know this is one of the months that
there will be two blue
moons that's right we have eliza our
beautiful astrologer who came and told
us that and the full moon is this
halloween which is so special and it's
on a saturday
so par-tay right so a sphere ice cube
with a little herbal tea a little
blue herbal tea really really cool
looking darcy see
every time i'm in your world i just
think i'm so plain jane and i suck and
then i see
that is not true it's true okay we need
to move to frankie and olive's table
because i always say the kids table is
where i always want to be
you know those are always the most fun
right and you have a fantastic detail
with this table that i really love
because it's so kid-friendly tell me
about it just black paper and a marker
and you can upgrade anything with a
marker
a kit a balloon turn it into a cat a
paper bag
um wait you did this on the balloons and
anyone can do it you just draw and add
some construction paper ears
okay darcy that is so charming and then
just like lots of fun details
um you know again using the pen to do
tic-tac-toe
and coffins for i like to have crafts to
keep business
kids keeps busy yeah and talking about
crafts
um you know because hulk masks are very
important
look at how cute we have a kitty mask
for alvin frankie with a candy chain
oh so and again all crafts you
definitely want activities to keep them
busy this is gonna
have fun and um you know for me all this
is about
the you know the celebration but it's
also about the process and doing it
together
and having fun putting it together well
also as parents right now you know we've
leaned a lot into
technology to sort of get through the
homeschooling and everything
so just crafts i think are so important
right now because they're
developmental they're tactile they're
busy people
they bring it together artistically and
it's just a great
bonding tool and a way to have fun so
yeah instead of diy i say d.i.t do it
together
do it together and like do it like darcy
yeah so whatever those letters are
i am always so blown away
d-i-d d-y-d-y it's g-i-l-d
darcy you're coming back next week and
we're gonna do more stuff because i just
love you so much and
darcy i am always so blown away by your
work it is like so spooktacular this
this skate
you